you're mine who the twine it was a
Marcel ticket good Angela is suffering
from malnourishment and the city's
fashionable
you know one time we had when we hired a
chessington for the family event
yeah I think she's into thinking yeah
for a family event and many girls came
and then she'll have the cream you can
edit this ugly okay check out the pink
green cake and we handle what is that
game around which came to get no there
is a logical the snake what is it that
means roughly the roller coaster roller
coaster rules even on the roller coaster
yes yes then yeah let me mention it and
then check abdul raheem green cane and
as much of a shock to him green and the
people who are around us and they say oh
[ __ ] I'm driving okay
and Jessica why don't you go on through
roller coaster and she said well you
know a yes and no yes the noises come on
come on come on then it is no time so we
want and the people say to the you know
the officer please please let them go so
we went together you like it to be
honest with you is big scary and I'm
trying all of the time he will say China
has lost a lot after one and he was
holding it since firmly you should see
me on the benches here on the tree and
then I was laughing I was laughing and
then at the end I said the stuff for
Allah Sheikh Abdul Rahim is making dhikr
for modulo Allah and um just make
laughing I said the stuff for a lot and
I started making dhikr video and it was
really a very nice experience
along with logic million but then you
know the camera they did not have a like
yeah we did not have a proper picture at
that time I don't know we did not being
healthy means you have to Hinckley
anyway this is possibly experience okay
as my wondering what a missile a
Medicare Superman sisters welcome to
Arthur chef again and well after share
another episode and this today's
question is we had an email from exist
are the worst intestines and she's
asking that obviously support a family
she has no other choice
and she's allowed to serve alcohol or
such book etc SBC and I'll Judaism yeah
okay this is a good question - Angelo
Sorrento salam ala rasoolillah first of
all it is good that you put that
disclaimer that she has no choice but to
work okay to support her family because
I'm not always in favor of sisters
working in different places
yeah yeah because we want our sister
really to be the best mother and this is
another story I'm sure that provokes
many systems because many of them they
want to have careers they want to have
this and that and at the end of the day
they ruin their real career which is
motherhood maybe you can talk we can
talk about this another time alone but
apart from that okay assuming that she
is genuinely needs that job and she did
not have any other choice
and we will focus on the issue of
serving alcohol and touching pork
etcetera
okay first of all you know in this
country and in the West in general it is
very rare for anyone on capitalist
system to find a job that is purely
hollow that is free from any other in
fact that some people said the
these days you know these days it is
very difficult to find a job that is
hugely hell even in Michigan coming okay
they all have some elements of and some
Halloween yeah so that question is which
harm can be overlooked and which alum
cannot be overlooked
yes now the harm that can be overlooked
is the harm that does not lead to a huge
attack yeah
for example no one is allowed to work
well in a pornography industry because
that leads to a huge attack okay even
banking system it should be avoided
now with this issue of common it is true
that comma leads to a facade the
drinking alcohol each officer that's why
the professor hesitate about comma it is
opanka by but the amount of dealing with
someone in working for a Tesco or sales
video
a rights of that is minimum is minimum
and you are not really facilitating that
and you are not selling it you are just
passing or sir
yeah Nina you are not even serving it
you are just what is it again
yeah or you are just moving the box so
you are not setting yeah you are not
selling dope on telling means you own it
and you sell it okay same thing with
four so if it is vanilla inshallah it
can be overlooked however we ask
brothers and sisters to try their best
to find the minimum power divide the
jobs with the minimum harm and also we
try to speak to the any management with
them in Tesco in any other of this is
super socia yeah so that they should
work only in hello suggested if they can
be here if they can inshallah okay thank
you sir for the ensemble of the suits
kind if you want and sorry just to the
basis for the answers that we have given
it a lot Allah Allah to us but Apollo
Hamas the bottom fear Allah as much as
you can yeah and that is the debaters
and Aeschylus mention number of examples
hope when what the hell you learn the
harpes riddles and this is our the way
to deal with it okay thank you for your
question here it's after a special our
email after [ __ ] our home L so calm see
if you see the question then answer it
inshallah and we can answer this as
effective as possible so next time Salam
alaikum
shoo-shoo hey give me one I'm sorry
subscribe should you